brian president trump is taking nevada  to court the trump campaign filed a  lawsuit against our state over its plans  to expand  mail-in voting for the upcoming general  election now the lawsuit takes aim at  assembly bill 4  and claims the bill's provisions will  compromise the election's integrity  it also claims it will prolong the  election and make voter fraud quote  inevitable despite research showing  voter fraud rarely happens with mail-in  voting  the president insists it will except in  one state and that's florida  over a long period of time they've been  able to get the  absentee ballots done extremely  professionally  florida is different from other states  it is extremely important to me  that our citizens do not have to decide  between their health  and their right to vote now our state  now joins seven others that will  automatically  send ballots to active registered voters  and we'll of course keep you updated on  that lawsuit